you look good though buddy what do you
been doing different we're exercising
yeah I've actually been lifting things
that I wouldn't normally left and
putting them over my head
are you really I go to the gym and [ __ ]
no I just like do a simple workout and
then I've always eaten pretty well so
I'm just staying on the diet mmm I have
a drank for eight months
what well yeah I mean which you know I'm
almost [ __ ] I mean I I know I didn't
want to bring that up I didn't want to
be on that out but yeah I almost been
since you [ __ ] dead right so it was
so sweet when I saw you afterwards
you're like you really looked horrified
that I almost died yeah you know here's
the thing though okay is there's because
I love you so [ __ ] much
when you here so you were in Colorado
correct yeah I had gone I just kind of
been like [ __ ] it so I had this summer
off from filming I had like a couple
shows and stuff so I basically was like
I'm just gonna drink so I drank everyday
cuz all I really wanted to do is just
drink and watch sports and like I never
had any of that or I could just do that
so I just was like I'm just gonna do it
so I did everyday I drank I'm a huge
sports fan so I just watch games and
just traveled it was super fun but I
just did it so much and drank myself
into a wall and anybody who drinks a lot
knows that once you get into that wall
where like now you now you have to drink
to just maintain Wow and then I just it
hit a like the biggest wall ever and I
went to Colorado and I just mic system
to completely shut down completely I've
never seen anything like that for and
then you would you so what did you like
blackout and just end up in a [ __ ]
ICU somewhere no I landed in Denver and
I had cocktails on the plane but I kept
vomiting and I was like oh it's not that
weird and then when I let in Colorado I
just drank at the airport I kept
vomiting and I'm like something's wrong
I tried to eat and it won't work and so
I realized you know you can tell your
body like gives you a heads up where
it's like okay this isn't a hand
and I literally called my agent I was
like hey something is wrong and I went
and I looked up like this kind of
medical place not a hospital but it was
like it just a checkup what I can yeah
and so I went it only had one star on
their yelp review and they don't care
about caring was it like an urgent care
yeah it was urgent care yeah yeah it one
star yeah all right well I've rolled the
dice this month so I went and they took
one look at me I didn't [ __ ] say
anything I was like hey what's going on
they're like oh you need a you needed an
ambulance and I was like yeah I'm good
and they were like no and they took me
to an ER and the dude was like I love
grandmas boy am i cool man and more
things and he was like yeah probably and
they took me to the ER and they were
like holy [ __ ]
just off looking at me and then I was
hooked up to tubes I was in the ER for
three weeks and they were like Mahiwal
they go people with quadruple bypasses
are usually out in like three days and
I'd say for three weeks
it was [ __ ] nuts I know but dick was
it like topsy-turvy like were they like
you're not gonna make it a tie were you
really lucid or were you like were you
do they have did they have you like
intubated or they put a tube down your
thigh was out for probably half of it so
I was there for three weeks I was
probably completely gone for a week and
a half oh I know I'm making like what I
would happen
I'm just making like I'm making like but
it was it was famous [ __ ] life it was
super bizarre
terrible yeah I mean I almost lost you
then yeah and it was pretty wild because
you know I long as I've been in comedy
and I he's the same one of you how many
people we've lost I mean it's just awful
anytime a comic dies it's just awful so
it was pretty it was pretty crazy oh my
god that would have been
a life changer that would have been so
[ __ ] terrible so then what when you
got out after three weeks you let me
when you were lucid and stuff did you
think yourself I'm done drinking for a
while or what yeah I was like I should
probably yeah you know you know I don't
know what's gonna happen in the future I
saying that is so reckless we were like
[ __ ] you but you know I I don't plan on
drinking I have a drink for eight months
is not a problem at all you know but I
mean you know if I am I gonna have a
[ __ ] Jager Bomb when I'm 80 I don't
know yeah ice 11 don't you you know I
relapsed in August after 17 years of
sobriety who did I did oh did you really
yeah so I had 17 years and I relapsed in
August but now I'm sober again but um in
what capacity as you relapse with pills
I mean no nut pills for me I just you
know mine was um tied in with my dad's
death and trauma and all that stuff so I
was going through a lot of emotional
[ __ ] too
but um yeah I was just smoking weed 24
hours a day but then I was shooting [ __ ]
and I was it was terrible you know I
mean I you know I was just I was
completely clueless and she almost
laughed and it was it was terrible
how long did that go on for I had gone
out for a pub Lee what two or three
months yeah and it was it was weird Nick
because usually someone who just smokes
weed there he was acting like a junkie
he was acting like this was this was
meth like he would he would line our
chimney with just weed paraphernalia and
I kept telling him like look it's just
it's it's weed it's not but I knew that
that was probably just one step before
something else cuz he was already acting
strangely even though it was just
marijuana like it was just around the
bend for him you know I would spend like
$1,000 I mean I was acting like it was
like crack like I I would go to every
dispensary in LA you never mean and buy
just a thousand of dollars worth of weed
and then hide it in the house as if it
was a leak on some [ __ ] like that was
acting crazy you know made you know
people will give you weed
[Laughter]
like it had like an adverse reaction
where people who usually smoke weed are
you know they're calmer he was acting
like a [ __ ] crackhead he wouldn't he
would only sleep two hours a night it
had the complete opposite reaction it
was like he just he had just been doing
cocaine all day yeah we'd like to suck
dudes dicks on the in the alleyways you
know just like crack behavior of it
picking scabs off my body bobby was so
high he wasn't showing his penis how
many times have you seen my dick you
think 78 yeah you know what's
fascinating about you too is is that um
even though during your you know your
crazy partying and all that kind of
stuff you know you still had so many
comics that just adored you and loved
you and wanted to take care of you and
I'm just glad yeah I mean you have even
like Sandler loves you so [ __ ] much
and you know you you have always tried
to get me into this world as well one
time when he was shooting when they were
doing that Zohan movie you brought Adam
out to see me to stand up just